[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
a while back I made a dear Apple video
basically begging Apple to update the
aging Mac Pro then a little while after
that I included the Mac Pro in a
top-five most overpriced
tech video and I even did a five-part
video series called the hackintosh pro
project which was basically to create an
alternative to the machine that Apple
just would not update the Mac Pro but
here we are in 2013 and of course
yesterday at WWDC Apple finally did it
they finally completely overhauled and
redid the Mac Pro so it's a very
mind-blowing machine so if had any
further ado this is a Mac Pro explained
now we were first showing the preview or
sneak peek of this new Mac Pro at WWDC
you got a lot of oohs and ahhs for the
crowd because of these weird lines and
these weird curves that they were
showing on the screen I will get to the
design in a second but obviously it's a
redesign machine completely from the
bottom up this takes almost nothing
other than the idea of a workstation
SPECT machine from the previous
generation Mac Pro so it is a Mac Pro
but it's pretty much not based at all on
the previous Mac Pro so one could argue
that it's not really actually a Mac Pro
it's just a new Apple desktop that Apple
called the Mac Pro to get people to stop
asking for a new Mac Pro but that's not
true this really is a pro machine it's a
Mac Pro it doesn't feel like a successor
to the very long history of Mac Pro's
and power Mac's that have that same form
factor but I can tell you that this is
definitely a Mac Pro so the ridiculous
specs of this workstation are the
easiest way to tell that it is
definitely a Mac Pro again as we have
the same workstation grade parts inside
and the most impressive part is that all
the internals are 2 to 3 times faster
than the previous generation highest end
Mac Pro which was not a slow machine at
all we're gonna duel Xeon CPUs of course
dual CPU support is classic for the Mac
Pros and also dual AMD FirePro
workstation GPU so these are extremely
high-end graphics cards but again
workstation grade graphics cards this
new Mac Pro also moves from regular SATA
SSDs which is what I'm using in the
hackintosh 2 PCI base storage and PCI
Bay storage is very very fast if you've
seen them already you know that you can
get 1.25 gigabytes per second transfer
speeds so I'm used to 6 or 700 megabytes
per second tops with my SATA SSDs 1.2
gigabytes per second for PCI base SSD
this is gonna be really really fast
storage and you also have extremely fast
RAM in this new Mac Pro coming in at
1866 megahertz instead of 1600 megahertz
and last thing when you flip it around
to the back the new Mac Pro has a much
improved IO array a whole bunch of new
ports that are awesome that the old Mac
Pro did not have so you have for a USB
3.0 ports you also have 6 Thunderbolt
2.0 ports and you also get HDMI and 2
gigabit ethernet ports thrown in there
so I like that there's HDMI that's
valuable and we'll talk about that in a
second but definitely a huge io
improvement now the whole point of a
desktop computer is the ability to
expand and upgraded in the future as
parts get better you can put in better
parts into your desktop now when we take
a look at Apple's 2013 computer lineup
you'll see that there's pretty much no
upgrade ability in that sense and for
years the Mac Pro was the last Apple
machine that you could upgrade the GPU
the hard drive the RAM you could upgrade
the previous generation Mac Pro and now
this the CPUs the GPUs the storage
basically all the memory everything is
basically guaranteed soldered to or
glued to the circuit board there is
pretty much no expandability so how do
they expect this to be a pro machine
apple says thunderbolt and that is why
there are six Thunderbolt 2.0 ports on
the back of this new Mac Pro that's why
they have an entire page on the Mac
Pro's website dedicated to trying to
convince you how awesome Thunderbolt 2.0
is and that's why they have that line on
their site that says that this is the
most expandable Mac yet it's because
they want you to believe that
Thunderbolt is a way of expansion in the
future I don't get me wrong Thunderbolt
is good
I love 20 gigabit per second transfer
speeds I love the daisy-chaining ability
and everything that's great but that
means that your storage all now has to
be external via those donor web 2.0
ports which means your nice simple
looking mac pro setup could go from
looking like this to looking a lot more
like this meaning you aren't going to
have a very clean setup if you tend to
use a lot of storage you can even throw
a new hard drive in there you have to
use external expansion if I
want to add a two terabyte hard drive I
can't just shove it in like I could in
any of the previous Mac brose you have
to use an external storage which is a
bit of a con I would say now the real
head spinners here with this new Mac Pro
are the size and the design the size and
the design are the most impressive very
different things about this versus the
rest of Apple's lineup on the rest of
the computers that exist right now the
size is mind-blowing okay it's nine
point nine inches tall by six point six
inches wide and that's really small okay
my the studio monitors I have right here
are bigger than the new Mac Pro in fact
if you want your mind-blowing you want
to know what matches the size of the new
Mac Pro in terms of height and width the
Nexus 10 the Mac Pro is the size of the
Nexus 10 ok if you have a 10 inch tablet
just hold it up and think about that
it's a Mac Pro I could punt a Mac Pro
across the room you couldn't even get
close to doing that with the old Mac
Pros so this size yeah mind-blowing this
tiny design is made possible by what
Apple calls a thermal core basically
long story short instead of having
individual heat sinks on all the
different parts that need to be cooled
like the CPU to GPU etc they have one
giant heatsink in the center in the
shape of a triangle that all the
different parts connect to so everything
cools at once and all the cool air and
warm air radiates out the top through a
single fan
it's a neat concept and it's a great way
of eliminating the need for a bunch of
different radiators and heat sinks and
fans and things like that now the design
is another interesting thing and I
happen to think that that's the most
interesting part of the Mac Pro it may
not be the prettiest machine in the
world we've seen some hands-on of it at
WWDC at a single one but it's a cylinder
so look around your room you probably
have square corners all around your room
you probably have your square computer
up against a square wall and it's
probably underneath your desk or up
against your desk on a square wall
surface this computer is a cylinder it's
forcing itself to not be up against the
wall or in a corner of your room it's
forcing itself to be a round cylinder
sitting on your desk and that's kind of
what Apple wants this is kind of a
marketing move to get it on the desks of
people who are using it and get it on
the desks of all the workstations that
happen to start employing them but the
the handles that were on top of the old
Mac Pro will now come in the
of that little scoop that goes into the
top that makes it look like Darth
Vader's trashcan or something or r2d2
for that matter it's an interesting
design I don't really like the fact that
it's glossy if you saw it at WWDC the
inside is matte black but when you put
the cover on the trashcan looking cover
is glossy on the outside it doesn't look
all that pro to me but I'll probably end
up putting some designs on it anyway to
make it look a little bit better than
that so that's the Mac Pro it's got the
specs of the future and the design of
some weird creation or collaboration but
honestly it's an interesting machine and
I like the fact that it's so powerful
and it'll have the specs to be able to
according to Apple edit 4k video while
rendering effects in the background
while connected to up to three 4k
monitors that's the specs of the future
right there because that's the setup of
the future editing 4k video on 4k
displays either way I can't wait to get
my hands on one and if you can't either
definitely leave a thumbs up on this
video below I can't wait to put this on
my desk and actually start to show you
guys it in person with some boxing's and
reviews and tests and things like that
but until then definitely subscribe for
the upcoming videos and more content
that I have on the way and thank you for
watching and I will talk to you guys in
the next video
[Music]
you